as we begin the New Year there are
concerns that Australia's famous Great
Barrier Reef could be placed on the
danger list of world heritage sites
because of climate change globally
nearly half of all Coral has already
died off now in a world first one
startup in Hong Kong is trying to help
Coral adapt to the problems humans have
caused with 3D printing and terracotta
raymianoscencio took a dive to find out
more
thank you
splashing into Hong Kong subtropical
Waters you might be surprised to learn
more Coral species live here than the
Caribbean yet this swath of the South
China Sea used to boast even more Beauty
what was here a hundred years ago we
believe that this area was a coral
Paradise David Baker is a choral
ecologist at the University of Hong Kong
those who are still with us from the
World War II generation you know these
people tell you that water was crystal
clear that there were Coral everywhere
but as Hong Kong industrialized runoff
and pollution bled into the waters so
Baker co-founded argue Reef in Eco
engineering startup to rebuild this
Paradise Lost His team in a world first
3D printed artificial Reef tiles made
from terracotta non-toxic and
biodegradable
they placed those on the Sandy Bottom of
a bay and seated them with living Coral
95 survived in the past two years how
did you even come up with the idea I
just thought to myself one evening that
why not tile the the sea floor like we
would tile a kitchen or bathroom floor
these tiles could have Global
application for Coral adaptation with
benefits to humanity reefs protect homes
and businesses breaking up destructive
waves from storms more than one billion
people depend on Coral from Fisheries to
tourism and medicine one of the biggest
red flags from scientists is that they
predict 70 to 90 percent of the coral
around the world will disappear in the
next 20 years
trying to make a splash as fast as
possible Archie Reef has now expanded to
Abu Dhabi its new industrial 3D printer
humming we have our own
facility Rico U archery's other
co-founder just moved from Hong Kong and
aims to help Coral move too
the Persian gulf's Waters can rise to
118 degrees higher temperatures can kill
you can assist migration to help these
corals
Bridge isolated Coral communities too
cut off because of Mass die-offs from
climate change
they can form a much stronger Community
really helps the ecosystem recovery
archery is hoping to help one tile at a
time for asking if you build it will
they come
the early answer is yes
for CBS mornings raymie inocencio Hong
Kong
that is some fascinating
development I was just I mostly
impressed that Remy got to go swimming
but we had to go swimming for a piece
yet no not yet but I'm hoping for one of
those uh the reefs are so important to
our ecosystem and what's been remarkable
in some instances is oftentimes when
water temperature rises and reefs die
off when water temperatures get back to
normal they grow back so there is some
hope that they will continue to do that
yeah well thank you Remy for that now